– Hallo, Pepe. Danke, dass
du so schnell kommen konntest.
– Worum geht's denn?
– Ich habe ein Problem mit meiner Webseite.
Ich habe gestern Abend
ziemlich lange versucht …
– Zeig mal her!
So, bitte!
– Das hast du mir aber anders gezeigt.
– Ja, schon okay. Frauen und Technik,
das passt eben nicht zusammen.
Immerhin kannst du Fahrräder reparieren.
– Entschuldigung?
– Was? Das war ’n Kompliment.
– Das soll ein Kompliment gewesen sein?
Du hast ja keine Ahnung.
„Frauen und Technik“ –
was für ein blödes Klischee!
– Okay. Aber jetzt konzentrier
dich mal wieder auf die Webseite.
Also, mach es so, wie ich’s dir gezeigt hab.
Ist eigentlich ganz
einfach – sogar für Frauen.
– Du machst es schon wieder!
– Was denn?
– Na, „sogar für Frauen“.
Es muss aber nicht immer alles
ganz einfach sein, damit ich es verstehe.
Es gibt bestimmt jede Menge Frauen,
die besser programmieren können als du!
– Ja, das kann sein, aber trotzdem gibt es
Unterschiede zwischen Männern und Frauen.
Und ich kenne ziemlich viele Frauen, die
eben nicht mit Computern umgehen können.
– Aha?
So ein Unsinn!
– Ja. Ich finde, die meisten Frauen machen
irgendwie alles komplizierter, als es ist.
– Männer auch.
Ich finde nicht,
dass das typisch weiblich ist.
– Machen wir jetzt weiter mit der Webseite?
– Ja.
– Wie wär’s mit Pink?